what is going on in florida right now
with coronavirus
is so hellacious
it's so dreadful it's so vicious that if
we're not careful
republicans might make ron desantis
their 2024 republican presidential
nominee republicans seemingly obsessed
with choosing
the worst people to be their nominees
and desantis is really
messing things up in florida let's take
a look at what's happening
florida started the pandemic not well
ron desantis very early saying closures
now open everything a wwe needs a place
for wrestling matches come to florida
ufc
wants to do fights come to florida bring
the cruise ships ban masks ban masks in
school on and on and on okay first of
all the case graph in florida
almost looks like a cartoon
since the end of july florida which is
just one of 50 states it represents just
six percent of the country's population
florida regularly hitting 20 000 cases a
day
25 000 cases a day day after day after
day
even these numbers may be low because of
lack of testing i got a report yesterday
from a viewer in florida who said at
doctor's offices there can be a
five-hour wait to get a covered test
and then the only other types of testing
you can get
are the ones that you have to book days
in advance and then you often don't get
the results for days either so it
appears as though at least anecdotally
the testing ability the testing
availability in florida is so dire
that the case counts are probably being
under counted okay it's it's uh
so
uh terrible in florida
to get a test
that many people who should be getting
tested just aren't and we are getting an
under count by every every sense of the
data on the on the ground now you might
come in and you might say well hold on
but but but if the vaccine makes covid
not serious
then cases don't really matter
since people who are vaccinated and gets
uh coveted don't really get sick right
well this is a florida explosion mostly
of the unvaccinated as we're seeing in
many states
florida's coveted hospitalizations have
hit another record high now you might
say david right before you went on break
didn't you tell us florida's
hospitalizations hit a record high and i
did but it's a new record we've we've
surpassed that number
coveted hospitalizations hitting you
high in florida a new report from the
florida hospital association showed 16
521 people hospitalized with the
coronavirus
up
773
from the day before and 162 higher than
this time last year
now then you might say okay
hospitalizations but we're better at
treating it now what about deaths
florida has done something
i guess we can call it slick
it's really completely dishonest about
death reporting as you can see here
as all of this ramped up in florida
death started to skyrocket but when you
look at the death count if you look at
the chart we have on screen
a few days ago all of a sudden the
deaths dropped to almost zero how how
did they do it oh my god ron desantis
fixed covid there's only there's almost
no deaths in florida anymore how do they
do record cases
record hospitalizations and the deaths
drop to almost zero well they are lying
and what i mean by that is they are
being very deceptive in how they report
deaths they are reporting deaths in bulk
infrequently and on a delay
so when you look the latest days always
seem low it looks like there's been this
big decline if you look at our chart
after a bunch of days with a hundred
deaths a day 110 deaths a day 120 deaths
a day suddenly flora florida had 11
deaths on monday
only seven seven deaths yesterday how
could this be the answer is these are
not real numbers in another week
they will come out and report the death
numbers for this week they will be high
the chart will be readjusted but then
again there will be blanks it'll be
almost zero for the dates next week that
are resent and it always looks like it's
a huge decline it's incredibly deceptive
because at any point a denier someone
who doesn't understand what florida is
doing with the death numbers they can
just pull up the data and say look
massive decline in deaths in florida
it's completely deceptive florida is on
covet fire
more than 5 000 students are now
quarantined or isolated
in just one school district we're seeing
pediatric icu cases in florida like we
haven't seen anywhere the entire
pandemic and this is after
a very short period of time
of schools reopening many of the
pediatric icu cases may not even have
been from in-school contagion yet so it
could get even worse in florida if you
can imagine and we're going to have more
coverage of the florida situation
on the david pakman show instagram make
sure you're following us at david pakman
show
uh if you want to know what i was up to
for the last 10 days follow my instagram
at david.pacman and we have a very
uh
if you want a vegetable break i had a
crazy backyard garden harvest waiting
for me when i got back from my trip
yesterday i posted a picture to my
instagram david.pacman find it follow me
and we'll be back right after this
one of our sponsors is curiosity stream
the only subscription streaming service
dedicated to documentaries i can't get
enough documentaries if you're the same
way you really should sign up for
curiosity stream which has a better
selection of docs than netflix hulu or
amazon
i'm always finding documentaries on
curiosity stream i can't find anywhere
else i recently watched david
attenborough's light on earth just
fantastic but they have something for
everybody politics economics history
technology psychology everything in
between i can watch at home on my tv in
my living room i can watch on my phone
if i'm on the go i love documentaries
and if you do don't waste your time on
other streaming services once you get
curiosity stream you will regret that
you didn't do it sooner when you go to
curiositystream.com
pacman you'll save 25 off of a
subscription
that will make it just 15 bucks a year
the link is right underneath this video